[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ja
ihr seid richtig wir haben heute sonntag
aber ich packe heute doch ich mag was es
ist was süßes es sieht zwar aus wie ein
spiegelei aus der pfanne
aber es ist was süßes aus quark öl teig
mit einer aprikose und nach richtig
leckeren vanillecreme der murat der ist
gerade noch mit den kindern unterwegs
und später weil ich ihnen bisher für
apple
samira würde sagen mama du trinkst denn
murat den papa denn ich sage ja eben
dieses spiegel einfach aus der pfanne
mal gucken was er dazu sagen wird dieses
dessert ist wirklich super schnell
zubereitet quark öl teig ist das sowieso
so ein blitz rezept und es ist wirklich
total lecker und auch wirklich mal was
den sonntag zum mitnehmen oder für ihre
gäste
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal die
zutaten für den pudding damit geht es
nämlich los der muss nämlich nach dem
kochen ein bisschen abkühlen
für die vanillecreme brauche ich 250
milliliter milch 50 gramm zucker 2
eigelb 25 gramm stärke etwas vanille
extrakt und 100 gramm quark für den
pudding gebe ich ihr team milch in einem
topf da kommt da zucker mit zwei gelbe
die stärke und auch dass vanille extrakt
also ich lasse es mir den quark raus und
kann die zutaten hier jetzt schöne
klümpchen frei verrühren
jetzt stelle ich den herd auf mittel
hoher hitze und kann dann den pudding
immer weiter hören und dann einmal
aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt ist der pudding fertig ihr seht er
macht bleibt und ich kann ihnen direkt
vom herd herunter ziehen und durch ein
feines haar sieht streichen
so kann ich nämlich eventuelle klümpchen
entfernen
guckte mal jetzt seht ihr mal dass wir
ein eingespieltes team sind
während ich nämlich noch den pudding
früher hat die andrea hier schon mal die
frischhaltefolie dass wege geht es bei
uns hier am dreh immer alles ziemlich
schnell geld man jeder meine gedanken
lesen kann weiß was denke ich gerade
es ist schön brötchen ja und ich denke
außerdem noch bei scea papa warum fragt
sie das habe ich nämlich einen baum
gesetzt und dadurch die ohrstöpsel bei
dir drin us-studie 10 euro der pudding
es ist schön cremig und jetzt kann ich
hier noch den quark einrühren
der bringt nochmal so ein bisschen säure
mit rein das ist richtig lecker und es
dann halt auch back teilchen kurz
einrühren und dann direkt an der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie abdecken
und kurz abkühlen lassen und die zeit
nutze ich dann um den quark öl teig
herzustellen
[Musik]
für den quark öl teig werden jetzt
einfach alle zutaten ganz kurz verbunden
und da müsst ihr nur darauf achten dass
der teig nicht so lange geknetet wird
weitere tipps findet ihr übrigens in
meinem grundrezept video
ich habe ich jetzt den fertigen teig und
er hat eine ideale konsistenz und den
kann ich jetzt kurz einteilen und zwar
einmal durch die hälfte dann vierteln
und je nachdem wie groß die teilchen
werden sollen können das jetzt einfach
ein bisschen kleiner machen
ich habe jetzt zwölf teile und die
werden jetzt ein bisschen flach
ausgeräumt und da kommt jetzt eine mulde
rein da können dann zum beispiel ins
boot zu nehmen oder auch einfach mit den
fingern so ein bisschen rein drücken und
so kann ich jetzt direkt auf ein
backblech setzen
[Musik]
und jetzt verteidigt die abgekühlte
vanillecreme hier drauf und drücke dann
eine aprikosen hälfte drauf und die
aprikose und die nehme ich einfach gerne
aus der dose
[Musik]
und so können sie jetzt schon gebacken
werden jetzt sind die aprikosen teilchen
gebacken und abgekühlt und damit sie
jetzt noch schön glänzen kommt noch
etwas aprikosenmarmelade trüber unter
business user schnee deshalb für die
deko und damit da jetzt nur auf dem teig
ist nämlich jetzt ein schälchen nächste
drauf und dann könnt ihr das einfach
schön drüberstreuen ohne dabei das ei zu
erwischen
und jetzt das aprikosen gelee oder die
fein passierte marmelade einfach noch
über die aprikose streichen
und ich finde es macht echt einen
deutlichen unterschied also dem park
würde ich nicht weglassen so jetzt lege
ich eins davon einmal in eine pfanne und
holte nur raten und darf demnach
probieren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schatz ich habe für dich gekocht das ist
kein deal dies ist keine ich habe dich
vor gehörte über mich geredet ja aber
ich muss ehrlich sagen mal ein paar in
der falle so fällt aber ich hab mich
echt aussehen perfekt ist eiweiß ist das
perfekte schau das ist dann kann es mal
probieren gern man kann es noch mal
probieren probieren
und wer möchte kann noch ein bisschen
drüber streuen das wollte jetzt aber
nicht um die optik nicht zu zerstören
mit der aprikose bitte nicht nur ein
eisen vorne große fete ein bisschen
'schon mitschneiden also mach meine
fahne nicht kaputt und ein bisschen er
einen hauch zimt finde ich mist auf
jeden fall genial was weiß ich besser
finden würde das ding also schmecken ja
ja ich bin noch mehr aprikose darauf
wäre ich finde die abmischung ist noch
besser auf jeden fall also ich finds
auch mit mehr ab der kurse noch schöner
wenn man kann ja auch den teig und
einfach kleiner machen man muss ja nicht
so einen rand haben wir hier so kann er
im prinzip einfach nur so und teilchen
machen und dafür dann mehrere dann kann
man auch die ganze dose aprikosen
aufbrauchen
ich fande 10 und die optik ziemlich
schön ja ihr könnt uns natürlich so
zubereiten wie ihr gerne möchte gerne
auch mit kleineren demokraten bisschen
besser schmeckt so müssen wir waren mit
kleineren aber echt lecker und macht es
nach dann hat er mehr spiegel einer
super cool also ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachmachen
ich bin mal gespannt wer heute zuerst
das fotoposter ich denke einige werden
es heute nach machen weil es einfach
super einfach ist und super schnell geht
und im rat sehr gut schmeckt also viel
spaß und nachbacken bei euch noch einen
schönen sonntag und bis zum nächsten mal
zählt
[Musik]